So it was a hundred pound cat is still going to be smaller than the dude that
it's attacking.
Did you ever get in a fight with a house cat?
Never.
No.
I've never gotten a fight with a house.
Can do all animals.
I am as well.
But I had a feral cat.
I raised him.
They're all fucking fair.
And Joe?
No they're not.
All this is a cat and it was actually born in the wild.
Really?
Yeah.
He was born in the wild and I had a stay with him in a room to get myself used
to him and get him used to me.
This is pre internet too,
by the way.
So this is like in the nineties and so I locked myself in a bedroom with this
kitten and just brought a stack of books.
I put a mattress in there,
brought a stack of books,
just hung out with his cat.
And every time I'd get knee near this calf cow would freak out and hiss at me
and jump on the curtains and fucking literally like climbed the blinds,
screaming and hissing.
And then I finally would get my hands on him and he would immediately start
purring and given in because once he realized it wasn't trying to eat him,
that I was his friend,
I would pat him and he would per allowed an Auntie Kat would pro.
It was crazy.
Like I developed this bizarre bond with this cat because it's cat was so scared
of the world.
I mean he was that scared of every reaction every time.
No.
And eventually calm down and be like,
it was the only one that could,
that could touch him.
Now I was the only person,
like my friends would come over,
he'd hiss at them.
He would like wow.
Like,
like let them know like bitch shit is about to get really crazy.
Like I'm not a regular cat,
but I could go up to him and I could pet him.
He was a feral cat,
you know?
Um,
what was my point?
Beginning this,
I dunno what,
what did we were,
oh,
okay.
Oh,
I had to get them fixed.
This is what it was the cat.
I had to get them fixed and I had to pick him up and I don't know how the fuck
he knew that something was going on.
Oh that's right.
Cause I was trying to get them in a laundry basket.
I was trying to put them in the lunch you basket because I wanted to bring him
to the doctors,
get them singly buddy who tried,
who he trusts comes at him with a fucking cake.
Not that deep into our relationship either because he's the only like 10 or 11
months old.
He sees reign in my house,
man.
He's lifting his tail up and just shoot and piss on my walls.
I was like,
hey you fuck dude.
He pissed all over the place.
By the time I,
I realized like I had to get him to a doctor.
You pissed at my house like 10 times because they just piss in the house and so,
and then I was worried like if you don't get them quick enough,
like you had to clean everything up deep,
clean all the carpets.
But if you don't get to him quick enough,
he just thinks,
well,
he's spraying from now on,
even after you fix something,
that can be a problem.
So I tried to hold onto him and put him in this laundry basket and to,
he taught me the fuck up.
He tore my arms up.
He just scratched me and Clyde me.
And he was remarkably strong.
This was a little cat.
And this was your friend,
like he,
when he was saying the same to me,
I thought you were my friend,
bitch.
I knew it.
You fucking prick.
So I had a $30 a blanket on him.
He was hissing at me and trying to get out of the room.
I had to throw a blanket at m and under the blanket.
I scooped him up and I put them in the laundry basket.
And then I slowly pulled the blanket out so he didn't suffocate while keeping
the lid down and then tape the,
the,
uh,
the laundry basket up so that I could put it in my car and he wouldn't jump out
my car and call my fucking face off while I'm driving.
[inaudible] Chevy chase movie.
Did you leave it at the vet and just walk away?
The vet was a good friend of mine who has since passed on and it was uh,
he was,
uh,
a really,
he that guy loved animals eat the cat whisperer.
He know.
He knew how to take care of it.
He knew.
I told him the whole deal coming in and you know,
he knew he knew how to handle it.
He's the only vet I've ever had cry with me over what animal?
I had a puppy that had distemper.
A friend of mine found these puppies at a gas station.
Someone was giving them away and he took a bunch of them and he calls me up.
He says,
Hey man,
you want a puppy there at the gas station?
I said,
yeah man,
bring that puppy over here.
Oh Man.
The puppy,
just after like a couple of days of being at the house,
we'd have these seizures like violent seizures.
It would just lie down and eyes would roll back and you can just pet it a little
bit.
It would slowly come back.
Then it would be weakened,
delirious,
and it would know it would happen.
And then towards the end it was having them all day long.
I mean it was just all day long.
And that's distemper,
distemper.
So how does it manifest?
Again,
it's just some horrible neurological disease that dogs get.
And if they don't get the right shots when they're young,
they can get this and there's a bunch of different horrible reactions and it's
fatal.
So I had to take him to the vet and the vet was like,
there's really nothing we could do with them.
He's having seat.
He was having seizures all night,
all night.
It was awful.
And he was like,
he's going to die and he,
you know,
any hour now,
we're going to have to put them down.
So he puts him down and he comes out in the hallway.
I mean,
I,
I held the dog,
I placed him down,
I gave him a kiss,
I said goodbye and he put the needle in the dog and,
and put the dog to sleep.
Then we both went outside,
man,
he was just crying,
just weeping.
You know the guys just the job.
Right.
He just loved,
he felt loved animals when he had a ton of animals.
Man.
He had cats and dogs and all kinds of shit and um,
he was killed by a drunk driver that was,
yeah,
yeah.
It was rough.
That was a,
that was a rough one.
I got an email,
I believe from his daughter.
It was a rough one.
The a super good dude,
man.
The WHO,
who are you crying more for?
The guy or the dog because the d well you started with the dog though.
You started getting teary.
The dog was a bummer,
but it was,
it was more of a bummer.
Even the way he was approaching it,
just human.
He was approaching it very humanly like,
you know,
most doctors,
I guess we're expected that they're like,
ah,
I'm sorry at this person is best on it.
Was that he wasn't on cal asked about it at all.
You know,
his,
his feelings about where super raw.
That's what I would imagine I would be as a doctor
just like,
I'm so pumped.
Good.
Sorry.
I do scare the fuck out of me with marriage.
In what way?
He would talk to me about his divorce and uh,
he would,
he would just,
he just grabbed me,
like,
grabbed me.
He goes,
don't you fucking get married?
Don't you ever do it was half joking,
half serious.
But he's like,
trust me,
you don't want to do that.
You don't want to have to go through this kind of a breakup.
He goes,
he goes,
you got a girlfriend right now.
You break up with her.
What happens?
You get broken up.
That's it.
Get breakup.
And he goes,
you don't have to see them in court every week for a year over and over again.
Whether it's just trying to take money from you and lying about what you've done
so they can get more money from you.
He went through a bad one and I believe some of his friends went through real
bad ones too.
And it just,
he was one of those dudes and I was like,
you know,
26,
27.
I was like,
Jesus,
man,
this is a man of science as a doctor.
He knows what he's talking about.
You know,
a wise man who knew a lot of shit.
So when he,
you know,
I was a moron.
So when he grabbed me,
let's listen.
Don't fucking get married.
You get married,
I got married.
He's just,
uh,
you know,
he was just a guy that,
I mean,
I really firmly believe when it comes to things like that,
there's this people that are just supposed to be doing what they're doing,
right.
And he was a guy that was supposed to be working with the animals like it.
It just worked.
Man.
He had the heart for it.
He's a veterinarian.
He probably seen how many animals die,
how many animals injured and still the guys crying.
A baby puppy has a baby dog.
Nobody wants to see a baby without a chance.
So the dude's guard his heart in the right place.
That's the guy you want to bring your animal to.
100%.
He's also the first guy that ever told me,
don't get my dog fixed.
Why?
Well,
he said,
look,
he goes,
don't let your dog have babies.
Don't be an asshole.
He goes,
but if you get your dog fix,
you've got to realize your dog's not going to have any testosterone anymore.
It's going to be tired.
It's going to,
it's not going to be the same doc.
And I was like,
really?
And he's like,
yeah.
And so of course I've got my dog faced and uh,
just would not fucking listen to this bed.
I got them fixed.
I was trying to calm him down.
He was a pit bull and he was very,
uh,
aggressive.
And when I went to it did calm him down,
but immediately lost like most of his energy.
He didn't,
he just didn't have the same,
he's the same energy anymore.
He was kind of like bummed out.
And it was weird,
the yellow lab that I had,
or we had to like,
uh,
when I first met Jennifer,
my wife,
uh,
she got pregnant shortly after we met.
Yeah.
That's how fucking viral,
I am.
Fearful like a,
like a cat.
So,
uh,
you know,
we,
we'd never,
like,
I'd never even owned a dog,
so I was like,
we should get a dog to see if we'd be good parents.
And so we went to the pet store in,
uh,
the Menlo Park Mall in New Jersey,
and,
uh,
looked for a yellow lab she had in her head.
She's like,
I had a yellow lab when I was a kid and they're the best dogs for children,
so let's go get a yellow lab.
I'd never had a dog in my life.
So I was like,
that sounds great.
I knew what they look like.
So we went to the pet shop,
try to find a yellow lab,
and we found this dog that was blonde leggy yellow lab.
And they were marketing it as a yellow lab,
but she'd been left behind.
All the other puppies had gone and she'd been there perhaps a little too long.
Like,
you know,
she wasn't a dog yet,
but she was fucking on the,
you know,
uh,
w what was the Brittany Spears Song?
Um,
I'm not a girl,
not yet a womb.
And that's where the dog was.
She was too big for the fucking cage.
Like her face was pressed up against it.
No.
So we were like,
what about this dog?
And it was been priced down.
He could see like 2000 marked all the way down to like 600 bucks.
And truly,
so we got that dog and you never seen it.
Like it was like something out of a fucking cartoon because we were the ones
that were like,
get out of this cramped ass cage and come with us out into the parking lot.
It's dog instantly bonded with us,
loved us.
So fucking much became so needy.
Um,
we called it Scully.
We're big fans of the x files.
So,
uh,
after a week of having that dog and the dog was a cup in our grill all the time,
just like,
thank you.
Thank you for fucking getting me out of there.
Like you are my people and Shit.
We were like,
we should get another dog to babysit this dog.
So the dog has a friend.
So we went instead of to the pet store,
we went to a breeder's Kennel,
like a pedigree place.
And,
uh,
they had puppies versions of fucking yellow labs and they were adorable,
like fucking 10 of them falling all over each other like an animated,
like a Pixar movie.
And Jennifer picks up one and bonds with it.
She's like,
this is the one,
let's get this one.
I went over to the counter and I was like,
all right man,
we just bought a dog the week before,
600 bucks.
And even then I was like 600 fucking bucks,
man.
They,
they,
they throw these things out,
you know,
we can get one for free and shit,
but I was like,
I've never paid $600 for doc.
So you know,
I went up to the counter expecting,
well that's the rate,
I guess the going rate for yellow lab,
600 bucks.
So I went up to the counter and I was like,
we'll take that one.
And The lady's like,
that'll be $4,000 and it was like,
for all of them,
I just want one.
And she's like,
these are pedigree dogs.
And I had just met Jennifer,
barely newer so I couldn't turn around and be like,
put that down.
That's too expensive.
I tried to represent.
So I was just like,
well 4,000,
we're paying too low.
We are stealing from you.
And we got that dog and to be fair,
we named him molder cause again x files,
Fan Scully and Mulder and Scully was just like happy heart that just loved
molder was so smart and fucking thoughtful.
He wrote my four best movies.
That's why he died.
I made tusk and Yoga hosers like without that dog writing for me.
How do you write for you?
It's a joke Joe.
He was funeral cause he's just saying he was so smart.
He was so smart.
How smart woody,
he's so smart.
He wrote my last few squares joke didn't quite land,
so I was missing something.
I wasn't paying attention.
I didn't set it up properly.
They're not a fucking pro.
But in any event,
um,
he uh,
he was wonderful,
but we got them clipped and his demeanor never really changed.
He was always very low key.
We called him Kilroy because he'd go to the other side of the bed and just look
up like this.
Yeah,
I got my mastiffs snipped and it didn't really change.
His personality stayed the same.
He stayed the same,
but he was always kind of a mellow dog.
We got a very big dogs.
I don't like to do too much.
We got a rescue last year,
year and a half ago that was like,
you know,
molder died a couple of years ago.
Um,
uh,
he was,
he made it to 15,
which is like fucking old,
big for a big dog too.
Yeah,
it's pretty deep.
Like a doc,
I'll stick around,
you know,
fucking like cancer,
but a fucking big dog like that.
Generally you don't make it past 10 11.
So we've got a lot of good years out of him and stuff,
but it was fucking horrible.
And I spent the last two years of scalies life,
um,
almost as rehearsal for molder.
They're yellow lab.
So what usually goes first is the hips and the back legs.
So scalies back legs when she just,
the rest of her body could work.
But she was literally dragging your carcass.
What was wrong with their legs?
They just went,
doctor was like,
this just happens.
They're done.
Wow.
And she was 1213 so she'd made it a while,
but I was took the just stop working,
just give out.
So the nerves stop fire in the lake stop and there's no muscle.
Yeah.
Wow.
So I put a scarf on to her.
The back end of her called the magic walking scarf and I would become the back
legs for her.
So she would walk and I would be the back legs and you know,
fucking get shit and piss all over and stuff.
But I'd Doug the dog,
so it was no big deal.
So I did that all the way up to one scholar.
He passed away and then molder was always very healthy and fucking mobile and
loved walking and stuff.
Super Athletic Dog.
Jen would take him up on Runyon Canyon and shit.
Then one day he had his back leg started dropping and your fucking heart sinks
because you're like,
all right,
Scully.
She wasn't that active.
So when she lost her legs,
like yeah,
it's a bummer.
But she wasn't like the run around dog cause she used to chase moldy.
You'd throw ball molder would run after and she would just chase molder and try
to bite his back legs to prevent him from doing it because she wasn't nearly as
fast molder was the go out guy.
He loved to fucking be active.
So when his back legs,
when it was like heartbreaking and then he stuck around for two more years.
So it was literally two years of me Walk Magic walking,
scarfing,
uh,
this dog.
Uh,
then he got to the place where he did it.
You know,
it wasn't just temper,
but when you were talking about it sounded so familiar,
he would do that thing,
this thing where he would be like,
oh,
and this would go on for fucking hours.
And you could tell it was exhausting for him and he couldn't fucking move.
So you know,
everyone in the family was like,
it's time to let them go.
And this was like when he first lost his legs,
but I was like,
are you fucking shitting me?
If like if I lose my legs,
you better fucking put a magic walkin scarf around my fat ass and not fucking
turned me over to the needle.
I like this is fucking family.
So I held onto them for as long as I could until he got to that where he was
like an obvious fucking pain.
And I remember I shot a video of it on my phone.
I still have it and it's not,
you know,
it sounds fucking cruel or sick,
but like it was,
it was just a reminder because every once in a while I got new eventually.
Like we would have to put him down and like it's such a weird relationship.
Or one day you're like,
I love you to death and I love you so much,
I have to fucking kill you.
So I had that video on my phone for the longest time so that when in like the
wee small hours of the morning,
I would wake up and be like,
you killed your best fucking friend.
I could watch that video and be like,
you had to,
he had like,
he wanted to go start was sick.
So the doctor came over,
we got the vet to come over to the house and um,
it was like a big deal.
It was like we all knew it was coming and shit.
I was flying home
from a Gig and I kept telling him like,
Jennifer,
like,
don't do anything,
just like freeze.
Like I'll be there as quickly as possible.
And so like Doctor Kumar,
who is our vet,
uh,
it was,
you know,
scheduled to come over and,
and that last fucking hour was probably hands down the most of my life,
man,
because we all knew what was coming and your program to s to stop that.
It all costs program to keep people around and keep yourself around.
And yet like we were just all sitting there loving on them,
knowing that like by the time Doctor Kumar gets here,
it's all done.
It was fucking hard.
It was artist thing in the world to do and he was still in pain the whole time.
So even though you knew you were doing the right thing,
it was like,
like,
I understand why that vet,
you know,
got emotional,
like,
yeah.